[MUSIC PLAYING]
[EXPLOSION]
My God.
If you breathe a word of
what you've seen here,
we'll do time for treason.
I hate this!
I know you do.
Do you have any idea
what a pain you are?
I think so, sir.
Jim, the beach is that way.
You all right?
You dare threaten me?
Thor, so puny--
What?
He was freaking me out.
Hey.
This is the first marker.
The path was a lie.
You're talking about
the moment of creation.
Open the doors and tell
the world the truth.
I'm Tony Stark.
I build neat stuff.
I got a great girl.
And occasionally,
I save the world.
So why can't I sleep?
Two more.
Girls waiting over here.
I got you now.
I got everything going for me.
Life is funny.
You girls.
It's all so strange
how things can
be so different than you think.
You know what I
always wanted to be?
President of the United States.
Look when you're in office,
you got to do a lot of things,
sometimes, that are not
always in the strictest sense
of the law legal.
But you do them because
they're in the greater
interests of the nation.
Wait, just so I
understand correctly.
Are you really saying
that in certain situations
the president can decide
whether it's in the best
interests of the nation.
And then, do something illegal--
I'm saying that when
the president does it,
that means it's not illegal.
Hi, everyone.
And welcome to the Academy's
Visiting Artists Series.
The film made
addition for sound.
My name is Teri Dorman.
I am a supervising
dialogue editor.
I also am one of the three
governors in the sound branch
of the Academy.
And it is--
I am really happy to be
joined by Peter Devlin
today, who is a
production mixer.
At the top of this, we saw
a few samples of his work.
Peter has been a production
sound mixer for over 30 years.
He's been nominated for an
Academy Award five times.
He has worked on over 75 films.
And it is my
pleasure to introduce
my friend Peter Devlin.
Hi, Peter.
Hi Teri, thank you very
much for that introduction.
And I should note
that there's some
of your work in those clips
as well, since our association
goes back many years.
Yes, I was lucky to have
worked on your tracks.
We've done, I think, seven films
together during that 22 year
period, I think.
But why don't we start
from the beginning, Peter.
Could you tell me a little
bit about your history?
How you got started
in the industry?
And what things might have
inspired you to go into sound?
Sure, well, I'm originally from
Belfast in Northern Ireland.
And in the '70s,
Northern Ireland
was going through
a turbulent time.
And I can remember
just the importance
of going to the movies.
And I just absolutely
loved going to the movies.
We lived in Belfast
for a period of time.
Then, we moved to a
little coastal town
called Port Stuart.
So it was quite difficult
to get to the movies.
But there was one movie that
I definitely wanted to see,
which was in the summer of '76--
'76 or '77, and it was Jaws.
Jaws was the film
that totally changed
my life and my direction.
And it was a film that
obviously got a lot of hype
here in the US.
But it was, I
think, a book that I
discovered called The Jaws Log
by the writer Carl Gottlieb.
And he worked on
the film as well.
But that book-- and
I'll just grab it here.
I actually still have
the book, The Jaws Log.
This was a behind the scenes
of the making the film.
And that just--
I couldn't wait to see
the film because it just
seemed an eternity from
when I was reading about how
the film was made to
actually seeing it
in the theater in Belfast.
And in the theater in Belfast,
you call it the cinema.
We went to the cinema.
And I went with my cousin who
was two years older than me.
And I remember just sitting
with such excitement.
And those opening
chords of John Williams.
And what was your
first job in sound?
Well, the thing is, my
father was an accountant.
The rest of my
family were teachers.
I went a very
non-traditional route
in that I was encouraged to
take up civil engineering
at the local university.
And what I wanted to
do was get into film.
And I have no idea how to do it.
My careers office
here at school wasn't
able to point me in
the right direction.
And my principal
of my school when
I was leaving in the
summer of '79, 1980,
he said to me this idea of
working in the film business
or television business
was pie in the sky.
It always stayed with me,
that line pie in the sky.
And I'm like, well, I'm going
to figure out how to do this.
And fortunately, there
was an advertisement
in the local newspaper.
And it was for a
trainee audio assistant.
And I thought, well,
the BBC produces
radio programs, television
dramas, that's a great way.
And of course, I knew
nothing really about audio.
I was fascinated with
film-- the language of film,
but knew nothing about audio.
So I remember I sent in the
application and thought,
well, if I get called
for an interview-- if I'm
lucky to be called
for an interview,
I need to do some research.
And I went into
the local library
and found books
and sound recording
and basically crammed this
information-- took notes down.
And I got a letter from the BBC
inviting me for an interview.
And I remember going for that
interview and it was just--
it was, I think,
a panel of four.
And they talked to me about what
is it I liked about the BBC.
What is it I liked about radio,
television, did I enjoy films?
And they were able to focus me
on just my general interests.
But then, they started to
get into the hard stuff
of sound recording.
And fortunately, from
my visit to the library,
I had enough experience to
skid through that interview.
And then, I did a
second interview
with the head of engineering and
it seemed obviously past that.
And then, got invited
to join the BBC.
So I had to go on a
training course, which
started, actually, it's 40 years
ago this month in April of '81
is when I set off from Belfast
to the BBC'S Engineering Center
just outside Birmingham.
A little town called Evesham.
And it was an
amazing facility that
had people that were working
in film editing, that
were working in directing
and camera and sound.
So the BBC gave me
this amazing training
and all sorts of disciplines.
So when I did my training
course, I went back to Belfast
and I worked in news, I
worked in current affairs,
I worked in radio dramas.
And I found myself leaning
towards the drama element.
I loved being in a
radio studio being
a participant in a radio drama.
Doing sound effects-- Foley.
So anyway, that's
the short version.
It's interesting
that your experience
is practical
experience as opposed
to going in film school.
But what got you from
Ireland to the United States?
Well, there's an
interesting journey.
So I'm working at
the BBC in Belfast
and I'm thinking,
OK, what I really
want to do is work in movies.
I'm going to cinemas, I'm
watching Apocalypse Now,
I'm watching Star Trek.
I'm really enjoying big
blockbusters from the US.
And I started to
write to studios.
I wrote to 20th Century Fox.
I wrote to Warner Brothers.
I wrote, I think, to the
producers of Steven Spielberg's
Indiana Jones to say, dear sir
or madam, I work for the BBC
in Belfast.
Could I visit the set?
Of course, I didn't get
very many responses.
But I got a response
from one filmmaker
that I admire hugely and
his name is Michael Mann.
I wrote to Michael Mann in
'87 and said, Dear Mr. Mann,
I'm a sound engineer working
for the BBC in Belfast.
I'm a huge fan of your
television series Miami Vice
because Miami Vice was one
of the more popular TV shows
in the UK in-- from 1985 to 87.
And I asked him, would it be
possible to visit the set?
Because I was really
intrigued with just--
it was a high--
it was a very glossy production,
big budget car chases,
and the music was
such an important part
of the sound of it.
So I sent this letter
off and it was within,
I think, a month
I got a response.
And I just remember it came
into the crew room in BBC
in Belfast.
And I saw the Miami
Vice logo and my heart
was beating so fast.
And I thought, OK, it's
going to be a rejection.
Dear sir, thank you
for your interest
but here was Michael Mann--
sound from Michael Mann
inviting me to the
set of Miami Vice.
So that letter changed
the course of my life.
So never underestimate the
power of the written letter as
opposed to the written email.
A written letter really
speaks for something.
So that's the first step
in my journey to the US.
It's also a good
lesson to anybody
wanting to get in the industry
is putting yourself out there.
And you never know.
All you've got to do is
ask at a certain point.
Persistence.
I mean, Chris Monroe, who's
an acclaimed production
mixer from the UK
talks about how
he was working at a gas petrol
station in the UK when he--
somebody pulled in in a car.
And he heard something about he
worked at the film studio at--
I'm not sure whether it
was Pinewood or Elstree.
But just from hearing--
overhearing that conversation,
Chris spoke to this guy.
And the next thing is that kind
of opened up the door for him
into the film industry.
Everybody has a way of
managing it, I think,
if they can follow their dreams.
Always to have that
focus and persistence.
Absolutely, I
think that's great.
And your first job
in the United States.
You moved to Florida.
Is that correct?
I moved to Florida.
And that really was a result
of that letter to Michael Mann,
again.
When I visited the set
of Miami Vice, I spent,
I think, it was two days
with the production team.
And I remember when I arrived
on set the assistant directors
were telling me, don't
talk to the actors.
And I'm like, I'm not
interested in the actors.
I want to hang out
with the sound team.
And the production mixer was
a gentleman called Joe Foglia.
And Joe was mixing the TV series
with a boom operator Scott
Blander--
sorry, Jeff Blander
and Vince Nuccio.
So that was a three person team.
And Joe contacted me when I went
back to Belfast after the fact
and said, hey, look, you seem
quite interested in working
in the US.
When I'm doing Miami
Vice, my company
does commercials,
low budget indies,
would you be interested
in joining the company?
So I went to my boss
at the BBC and say,
I've been given this
opportunity in the US.
Could I go out there
and see what it's like?
Could you keep my job open
here at the BBC in Belfast?
And he said, well, that sounds
like a great opportunity,
but we definitely would not
keep your job open here.
You got to go for it.
So I left in Christmas of
'87 having been with the BBC
for almost seven years.
And thought, OK,
I'll give it a go.
And I went to Miami
and that's where
I started my career in the US.
And after that, were you working
on many feature films in--
No, I started in a
television series,
which is called The
Adventures of Superboy.
It's my kind of first
foray into superheroes,
which I continue to
this day having just
worked on Wonder Woman
84 that just came out
recently and in the world
of robots with Transformers
and Iron Man.
So it all started with The
Adventures of Superboy,
which was produced by the
same team behind the Superman
movies.
They produced a movie called
Christopher Columbus Discovery.
So that was kind of the
first big feature film I did,
which was in 1991.
And that was with Marlon Brando.
That was kind of early
days in this sound career.
And in, may I say,
just technically
to that was in the days
of 1/4 inch recording.
Recording on tape.
And we've come a long way
since those 1/4 inch days.
I think we can get into the
technology changes a little bit
later.
Because that certainly affected
your career and my career.
But when you first started, did
you start as a production mixer
or did you start in an assistant
capacity as a boom operator?
No, I started as an assistant.
I mean, the wonderful thing
about working from the BBC
is one week I could be working
on the Elstra orchestra
setting microphones,
the next week I
could be working one of
the current affair shows,
running the board, which was, I
think, like a 16 channel board
with outside sources
of telephones.
And if you were doing a live
link to a reporter in London
or in Wales or Scotland.
So working in-- at the BBC
give me that opportunity just
to look at all the
different areas of sound,
whether it be working at a
boxing match or a soccer match,
rugby, a musical show,
traditional music--
traditional Irish show.
There's a TV series
called, "As I Roved Out".
.
And each week, they
had a different band
that would come in.
Sometimes it was Van
Morrison and the Chieftains.
So I would have been working
in the floor as an assistant.
John Lund was one of our senior
recording engineers at the BBC
who was absolutely
amazing on the panel.
So I was lucky to have
great mentors at the BBC.
Dixie Dean, who was
head of the drama.
He was the person that
would always end up
mixing on the drama show.
So Dixie was somebody that
took me under his wing
and allowed me to do second
boom on the fisher boom, which
is the platform boom on dramas.
And then, there was another
mixer called Peter Lindsay
that worked in film dramas.
I worked with him.
So I had a little bit of time
in all the different disciplines
of sound.
And that's what was so great
about working for the BBC.
Being able to work in
those assistant capacities.
And also stepping up to mixing.
When I left the BBC, it was--
I was an audio supervisor.
So I was starting
to do bigger shows.
But my love was really I wanted
to get into feature films.
It sounds like your experience
there would benefit you
later in some of the
films that you took on
because you were
working with crowds,
you were working with
various situations that
would enable you to do
films like Any Given
Sunday where you were
dealing with large crowds.
Yeah, you bring up
Any Given Sunday.
And I think that was a
particularly difficult film
because it was--
technically, it
was just at a stage
where we were
still transitioning
from digital audio
tape to what's
going to happen next
as a recording medium.
And it was where I
would have loved to have
had a lot more channels to--
because there was so much
happening on the different
sets that we were filming on.
But there's a scene in the
film that so many people
have talked about.
And it was where Al
Pacino as Tony D'amato
was giving a pep talk to the--
the teammates-- his team
in the locker rooms.
Because that's what living is.
The six inches in
front of your face.
Now, I can't make you do it.
You've got to look
at the guy to you.
Look into his eyes.
Now, I think you're
going to see a guy who
will go that inch with you.
You're going to see a guy
who will sacrifice himself
for this team because he knows
when it comes down to it,
you're going to do
the same for him.
That's a team, gentlemen.
And either we heal
now as a team,
or we will die as individuals.
That's football, guys.
That's all it is.
Now, what are you going to do?
[SHOUTING]
It's such an
inspirational speech
that I just-- every
time I see it,
it stops me because
I get goose bumps.
Because I remember
that day and I remember
Pacino was just so perfect.
Somehow or other, you
compensated because what's
on the screen is quite amazing.
If you look at that
film and analyze
how many things are
going on at once,
and you're coverage of
that is pretty phenomenal.
As a sound mixer, it's
all about the authenticity
of performance.
And even looking at
those opening clips
that I was looking
at this morning,
whether it be Chris Pine
as Captain Kirk or--
and Charlize Theron as
Aileen Wuornos in Monster.
Our job as sound mixers is
to record a true performance.
And I'm always amazed at
how between action and cut
that they create this magic.
And the role of a
production mixer
is so different to what
happens in post-production.
We're just trying to fight
all the different elements.
I think this is a
good point to make
at this point in
our conversation
is that the different
levels of sound
and the fact that
you're at the beginning
and what you are
recording and capturing
is the true performances of
the actors, the actual what's
going on on the set, whether
or not it's a practical set
or whether it's a sound stage.
And your position on
this is the beginning
of that circle of talent,
specifically dealing
with your production mixing.
I'd like to know who your team
of people is that back you up.
On any given project, how
many people are with you?
Well, traditionally,
you have yourself
as the production mixer and
you have your boom operator
and you have a utility.
And that utility is the--
I was going to say least
experienced, person
but you really need
an experienced person.
Because the utility really is
a second boom operator as well.
And he or she may not be as
experienced as the main boom
operator.
But they have to come in,
normally, at the last minute
to be the additional boom.
Now, because of the way
films have become bigger,
there's more cameras.
There are more-- there
are bigger sound crews now
in the UK.
You would find Simon Hayes when
he was doing Les Miserables
or Chris Monroe who's on
the new Mission Impossible
film is working with--
their term as assistant sounds
to first assistant sound
and a second assistant sound.
And they're sometimes trainees
on those films as well.
So you've normally got a three
or a four person sound crew.
On Any Given Sunday,
it was much bigger
because we were able
to have a second unit.
But the boom operator and the
second boom operator or utility
are basically your eyes
and ears on the set.
They're your voice on the set.
And I worked with Kevin
Cerchiai for many years
who's originally from Miami.
He now works in Atlanta.
And there's a
shorthand between you.
I'm sure you find yourself--
when you're in the cutting room
if you're working
with another colleague
and you've worked
with them for years,
there is a shorthand
between the two of you.
You know exactly how
each other works.
So you and I have both
worked on Michael Bay films.
And Michael's films
are big, spectacular.
Pearl Harbor was a
tough film because
of the scale of the film.
But also the fact
that Michael likes
to use multiple
cameras and also likes
to use a lot of
pyrotechnics effects.
And you're trying to get
that dialogue in there.
And if there's a film that
changed the course of my life,
it was working with
him on Bad Boys.
I need backup on Canal.
Now.
[GUNSHOTS]
Just get ready to shoot.
[ENGINES REVVING]
Police.
Stop the car.
Don't show me your badge.
He has a gun, shoot him.
[GUNSHOTS]
His films are big and bold.
The sound design is big.
And sometimes, it's
a wrestling match
to save that production
track, as you well know.
Yes, I was going
to say with the--
the thing is you've
now worked with Michael
Bay on several films.
Does that give you a
shorthand with the director
so that you possibly have his
ear so you can communicate
to him whether or not the
sound in that particular area--
I know Michael of all
people is very concerned
about his visual shot of things.
I remember in Pearl Harbor there
was a scene in the hospital.
And the curtains were blowing.
And it was the wind machines
that were blowing the curtains.
And he didn't care
about the dialogue
at that particular
point, he wanted
to make sure that those
curtains were blowing.
First of all, when it comes to
the actors within that scene,
you want to make sure
they're all radio miked.
There used to be a
time where you would--
when a director comes
in to block a scene,
you would try to say,
OK, we can boom this.
We can maybe use
a radiomic there.
But now, it's
traditional to kind
of put radiomics on the actors
because you don't have time
to make that change.
And back in 2000 when we
were shooting Pearl Harbor,
I was using a Diva 2, which
is a four track recorder.
And I remember when Michael
blocked that scene, I'm like,
I don't have enough channels.
I don't have enough
channels on this recorder
to be able to do this scene.
And then, I think I
pulled in probably a DAT
machine, which was able to give
me an additional two tracks.
And then, you start
to prioritize, OK,
so we can use a boom mic
on this part of the scene.
We can use a radio here.
So it's really just
try to isolate and look
at the priorities
within that scene.
And today, behind me
here, this recorder
is able to do 24 tracks.
I would love to have
had that back then.
But you do what you
can with the tools
that you've got not knowing
what lies ahead in the future.
But that particular
scene, because
of the movement of,
basically, the boom operator
Donovan Dear moved
with the camera.
So it was almost
documentary style.
Almost bringing what I learned
from my background and working
at the BBC and just what
one microphone can do.
And I'll give you an example.
I have a little microphone here.
One microphone can do so
much to capture a scene.
And there are times
where you can just
get focused in putting too
many radiomics out there.
So but one microphone
can do so much.
And probably, a lot of that was
done on one microphone as well.
And we like to use stereo mics
as well for crowd sequences.
I think people
also need to know,
you're not actually
right there where
the action is taking place.
You're set aside.
It's kind of hard to describe
your physical distance
from where the
actors are performing
that particular scene.
It's mostly-- you touched on
it to say that it's your boom
operator that's right there.
So I think it would
be helpful to show
your distance from the
actual scene being shot.
Yeah, I mean, on
Any Given Sunday,
I was quite far from the action.
And we would have to
run a multi-cable out
to our wireless receivers
to get the signal back.
So every project is different.
And now, with the reality
of the COVID world,
you even can be further
away from the action.
I like to be closer than
many people because I like
to feel a part of the action.
I love to be able
to walk on the set.
I love to be able to see
the problems that the boom
operators have.
But yeah, normally, I'm maybe
within 100 feet of the set.
And the sequences
in Pearl Harbor
where the Arizona
was tipped over,
I was very far away
because that set so huge.
And you're pushing the
technology of the radiomics,
too.
Because I remember Donovan was--
Donovan Dear who's booming
on that particular film.
Really, we were just at
the end of our transmission
path for our radiomics
with where he was.
And the beauty of what you do
is you can fix all our mistakes.
On that very thing, I
think all of us, you know,
whatever, I get through
my hands and goes
to a rerecording mixer.
But it's fun dealing
with your tracks
because they're so crisp.
Can you go over
what your process
is when you start a film?
You go and do a
technical scout on where
they're going to shoot.
Do you see what
your problems are?
Who do you consult
with when you're first
starting on a film?
To me, that's a
really important thing
to do is to be able to go and
see the practical locations
that you're going to shoot in.
An sometimes, it's a question
of timing and logistics.
You're in another movie.
But when I break down
a script, the one
thing I'm looking for is how
many actors are in the scenes,
is there going to
be music involved,
is there going to be
additional manpower
that we're going to need?
For example, with
Black Panther, that
was a film that I wasn't able to
go on the technical scouts on.
They were shooting at
a place called OFS.
That was doubling for Wakanda.
And unlike Wakanda, we
were dealing with a factory
that where half of it
was a working factory.
So you would hear
forklifts, transformers,
and also the local interstate.
But from the production's
point of view,
they had this huge
parking lot where
they were able to build
these huge blue screens.
And in particular, it
was a huge sequence
with T'Challa and Killmonger
and Forrest Whitaker
where they go to battle.
And at that point,
costumes weren't an issue.
It all had to be
boomed because it
was just bare knuckle
fighting and swords.
What we dealt with
was three cameras.
We were doing three cameras.
And wides and tights.
When you shoot wide and tight,
that can always be a problem.
Because you're trying
to get the microphone
to service the closest camera.
And fortunately,
we had blue screen,
so we were able to really
push the frame there.
But the one thing that
we were dealing with
was because of the
water-- because we
were shooting at this waterfall,
there was practical effects.
And the cameras all
had special adapters
on the lenses that would deflect
the water if it hit the lens.
The problem is that
they would start it up
during the dialogue.
And part of the job as
a production mixer, it's
all about negotiation.
You got to negotiate with
the gaffer about the lighting
ballast that's
making a noise on set
or the camera operator
who is shooting
a wide shot on a tight shot and
we talk to the director about,
is there any chance we can
shoot the wide shots first?
But our job has now
become to be able to adapt
to those circumstances.
And there are some directors
that are pretty adaptable
and they understand
the difficulties
that you're having.
And then, there are
other directors that say,
we've got to go.
We don't have time.
I'd love to be able to
accommodate sound here,
but the sun's going down.
This three camera set up we'll
just make my life much easier.
And sometimes, there's not even
time for that conversation.
But that particular
sequence was worked out well
because we talked
to the camera team
and they turned this
adaptor off so that we were
able to get the dialogue clean.
And at the end of the clip
that our viewers should
be able to see, you'll hear
the high pitched whine come in
after Forrest Whitaker
says his line of dialogue.
Let the challenge begin.
[SWORDS CLANGING]
You.
So that's about negotiation.
But we didn't know that
the camera department
were going to have those
elements on their camera.
So that was problem
solving on the day.
One thing as a production mixer,
it is about problem solving.
You're in real environments.
It's real life.
You showed me a
prime example of that
and you asked me to
visit the set once.
And I think you were
shooting Daredevil.
You were in downtown
Los Angeles.
And this is a prime example
of them not allowing you
on a scouting to know
what your location is.
Because you invited me up there.
You were up on the roof
and you said to me,
look what I have to deal with.
There's gravel on the rooftop.
And these actors were
walking all around,
which means that anything
that was being recorded
was going to pick up their feet.
But you quickly adapted.
Can you tell me
how you did that?
It's funny thing, when
I think about Daredevil,
I think about a cricket
that was chirping
during a particular scene.
George Flores, who was
my utility, literally
trying to search out for
this chirp during a--
it was one of the romantic
moments between Ben Affleck
and Jennifer Garner.
But if the camera's
not seeing the floor,
we would normally
put carpeting down
to try to muffle any
noises that are going
to obscure the soundtrack.
That's just-- I mean, you watch
a movie like Downton Abbey,
and hard surfaces, hard floors.
I just remember in front
of Downton Abbey there
was this huge gravel area.
And I remember seeing a
behind the scenes photograph
of the amount of
carpets that were
put to kind of muffle the
footsteps of the actors
as they move around.
I've worked with a director
Joel Schumacher who
when he saw me putting carpets
down got really irritated
and said, I hate
the sound of Foley.
I want natural sound effects.
But the natural sound
effects obscure the dialogue.
So you're trying to
strike a balance.
There are films that--
it's funny, when I think about
Foley, I loved good Foley.
There was Cate Blanchett
in the film Elizabeth.
I just remember the beauty of
those foot steps that are--
some were done on location,
where some done afterwards.
And that is, I'm thinking
about all the elements
that go into the
work that we do.
We try to strip
everything away to give--
to make it as clean as possible
for people in your world
to come in and use
their imagination
to tell a different story.
For example, Chris Pine
did a walk and talk
in Wonder Woman 84.
And Chris drags his feet.
And I would have to
say to him, Chris,
can you pick your feet up?
Because his scuffs
on the concrete
was obscuring the dialogue.
We eventually-- thanks to
the wardrobe department,
we actually resoled his shoes
whenever we made the company
move to the UK.
The fact that we can get the
wardrobe department to work
alongside us to make changes.
I wanted to bring
up some of your work
that you've done that's quieter.
That's a dialogue sequence.
Something like Frost Nixon.
And I had the pleasure of
working with those tracks.
And I just want people to
realize that because of the way
you recorded these
things, the sound itself
becomes a dramatic part of
the emotion of the scene.
There was a particular scene
with the last interview
between Frost and Nixon.
And his swallow, his
inhale, his exhale,
were so dramatic
and so clean that it
made my job really easy.
And it sounds pristine.
Is hunt.
Three, don't we have to
handle the Hunt situation?
Four, get the million bucks.
It would seem to me that
would be worthwhile.
Five, don't you
agree that you better
get the Hunt thing going?
Six, first, you've
got the Hunt problem.
That ought to be handled.
Seven, the money
can be provided.
Ehrlichman could provide
the way to deliver it.
Eight, we've no choice
with Hunt, but the $120,000
or whatever it is, right?
Nine, Christ, turn over
any cash we've got.
And I could go on.
Now, it seems to me that
someone running a coverup
couldn't have expressed
it more clearly--
Look, let me just stop
you now right there.
Because you're doing something
here, which I am not doing
and I will not do.
Throughout this
entire broadcasts,
you're quoting me out of
context, out of order,
and I might add, I have
participated in all--
Is it more difficult to shoot
a plain book dialogue scene
than it is an action scene?
It can be.
With Frost Nixon,
that was a film
where these two
actors had already
worked on the stage version.
So they were
incredibly prepared.
And I can only think
of two occasions
where they flubbed
their lines in the film.
They were so perfect.
Michael Sheen as David
Frost and Frank Langella
as Richard Nixon.
And what I loved about
those guys as well,
Michael Sheen is
a great character.
Very funny.
But Frank Langella stayed
in persona as the president.
So when we had to put
a microphone on him,
we had to call
him Mr. President.
I never saw him out of character
through the whole movie.
And that big final interview
that you talk about,
the silences were
part of the scene--
part of the dramatic moments.
And we were using
close mics and we also
had their period
microphones as well
because I gave those
to you as a choice
to be able to use if needed.
But I just remember
that it was electric.
And I think David Frost
had actually come to set--
the real David Frost had come
to set during those final days
on the film.
And it's a film
that I'm certainly
very proud of because it is--
it's all about the dialogue.
And Hans Zimmer did the score.
And there's a
minimalism to his score.
And music is such an
important part of films
because it can move you.
And we have no idea how a
film is going to end up.
My job is to record
the performance
as well as I can to give it
to you where you can clean it
up and assemble it and give
it to the rerecording mixers
and maintain that authenticity.
And for the composers to come
in to punctuate it with the way
they do.
And the Foley artists.
And Midge Costin's
documentary Making Waves,
you talk about that
circle of talent.
All these different
people that come together
that we don't always
know each other.
And I've been
fortunate to know you
over the course of 20 years.
And I still get
excited when I go
to a dubbing stage and hearing
that original production track
and how it's improved and how
it becomes just a new life
form in itself because
of the talents of others.
Because I would be lost
going into a protools session
and cutting a scene.
And you would be lost
coming onto a set
and dealing with the
politics and the machinations
of a production.
It's the collaboration
that goes on between
these different elements of
the soundtrack of the motion
picture that are so wonderful.
It's even the choices that
are made on a dub stage.
Should we go on to--
Some questions
from our students.
Our students.
I do have-- maybe we should
clarify the term sound design.
Can we go into that a little bit
so that people can understand?
It seems to me that sound
design starts from the script.
And it starts from between
the dialogue, the descriptions
of what is going to take place
in that particular scene.
And it carries through to
the director's vision of how
he wants the film to sound.
Your contribution is
part of the sound design.
My contribution is part
of the sound design.
There are also people
that do sound design
for specific elements of,
say, non-existent creatures.
But I just want to clarify
that sound, in general,
is so many different levels.
And maybe you can
touch on that, too,
a little bit before
we go into question.
I've been asked
so many times when
people have come
to visit me on set,
do you put the music in now?
Do you do the sound effects now?
They think that what we do on
set is the finished soundtrack.
And people have no
idea of just the number
of tracks and the
weeks and months
that go in to
finish sound track.
And just how a rerecording
mixer sound designer
looks at a script so
very differently from me.
I mean, I touched
on this earlier.
When I look at a
script, I'm looking
at how many actors am
I going to be working
with in a particular scene.
Does it mean I'm
going to need more
channels on my mixing console?
More radiomics?
When you look at
my notes, you're
looking at those problem
areas where there may be
noise obscuring a performance.
The sound designer is
looking for creative moments
that he can find
within the script that
may not be in the words.
I look at a film like Gravity
that won the Academy Award.
So much of that
takes place in space
with one single character.
And it's about the silences and
the breaths and the moments.
And that's also where the
score can come in and just
bring you to a whole
other level emotionally.
Sound is what I find
creates emotion for me.
When you turn the
sound off in a film,
it doesn't become
as interesting.
It can be the most
beautifully shot film.
But it's the sound
that brings you in.
It sucks me in.
It's also the idea
that, eventually, this
will be in a theater again.
And you never want
to have somebody
say, what did they say?
You want to make sure that
everything is audible.
That nothing pulls you
out of the dramatic
or the comedic moment, either.
So you want to make sure that--
our craft is invisible.
Thinking of people that want
to get into this industry.
It is a different world today
because of the internet.
Because of the ability to
shoot a film on your iPhone.
And also just-- I
was illustrating
this little microphone here.
This can do so much.
You have one microphone and
this is a little lavaliere
microphone here
and a transmitter.
You can tell a story with
your camera with those--
I mean, I'm still
using those today.
Still relying on a person
holding a microphone just out
of frame to tell a story.
And the tools are all
there for film students
to be able to use
to tell their story.
I mean, I was looking at some
of the videos on FilmAid.
And it was a little
documentary just looking
at life at the refugee camp.
And it was shot very simply.
But it's all about the
story that's being told.
And sound is part of your story.
And I think it's great
that what FilmAid is doing.
And what this program
is doing to be
able to bring our knowledge
to a whole new audience
and to inspire as well.
People that have touched
my life and have allowed
me to take this journey.
There's a young man
called Willis Abuto
who lives in Nairobi.
And I got to know Willis.
I think it was when I was doing
the last Transformers films.
I was flying to Namibia
only for two days
and we were looking
for a boom man.
And because of the
power of the internet,
because of the power
of social media,
I saw that Willis was
a sound mixer working
and in Nairobi and Kenya.
We exchanged conversations.
Unfortunately, he
wasn't able to join me.
But he's somebody that I now
followed in terms of the work
that he's been doing.
And he's very busy as a
sound mixer in Nairobi.
And I was just talking
to him last week.
And we were talking about
microphones and the problems
that I have here,
he has over there,
whether it be wide and tight
shots or noisy locations.
It's fascinating to see
how you speak the language
whether you're thousands
of miles apart,
it's the same language.
So you're working in sound.
You connected with someone who
you became a mentor to someone.
By your experiences,
you can help them.
And it's a way of
paying it forward.
And I find great satisfaction
in finding these diamonds
and finding these
people that are
interested in doing sound
and carrying on the work
that we do.
So I think whether it's
FilmAid or whether it's
your connection to the sound--
the production sound
mixer that you found,
it's all a worthy
journey and it's
giving them the opportunity.
So I think that's great.
I actually think we covered
most of the questions that
were asked in advance.
There were some things
that it came up as
to having tough conversations
with various departments.
This was one of the questions.
Having a conversation with
the camera department,
having a conversation
with the director,
with costumes about
how it relates to sound
and how you navigate that.
Well, you're talking
about costume there.
Ruth Carter was such a
help on Black Panther.
Because when I saw the costume
for Black Panther, I'm like,
how can we get that sound good?
I mean, how are we going
to get that sound at all?
Because it just looks
like a leather suit.
But it was actually transparent.
There was a spot that we were
able to put in the perfect spot
on Chadwick's chest.
And it was-- acoustically,
it worked out great.
But Ruth and I started
talking very early on.
And she was very aware
of what we needed to do.
And that's what's great about
being able to have that time
to work with those
departments to figure out
where the problems can be.
On this last show that I did, we
were dealing with noisy lights.
And that was a thorn in my side
through the course of the film.
And 20 years ago,
I think I would
have been just so distressed.
But now, I know there are tools
that can remove that background
noise.
It doesn't make
me happy that I'm
having to deal with
it on the time,
but at least they're there.
Technology helps us sometimes.
The technology changes
are coming along
and I think will help us in
all kind of areas like that.
If I could just mention one
thing about learning always
being educated.
Because I'm still learning.
There's a film that the Academy
screened last year that I
got to see it before COVID.
And it was from 1936 and it
was a black and white film
and it won the Academy
Award for sound.
And it was with Mary
Astor, William--
Walter Houston, and it was
directed by William Weiler.
It was all shot on stage.
But there was a sequence
that takes place in the boat.
And they built the front
section of a boat on stage.
And I could see the hair moving.
Now, when it comes to her moving
and their clothes ruffling,
you're talking
about Pearl Harbor.
You're talking about noise.
On Wonder Woman, we had to
deal with wind effects in that.
And it is so difficult. So I'm
watching this film from 1936
going, how are they doing that?
How on Earth are they
getting such grit?
Because that does not sound like
it's being replaced afterwards.
So and even last week, I was
looking at a new microphone
that I haven't used before.
And I was like, oh,
this is interesting.
This is something I
could definitely use.
So you're always learning.
Absolutely.
Peter, I could talk
to you for hours.
And unfortunately, we
are running out of time.
I want to thank you.
And I hope that everybody
listening to this
gained a little bit of
knowledge and a little bit
of understanding.
And we could sort of
pull back the curtain
on what we do in sound.
So thank you very much.
Thank you, Teri.